À travers les époques les dangers,
une grande aventure les appelle !
C'est, c'est, c'est l'Épopée Temporelle !!!
[Voix off]Comme on se retrouve !
Tu te rappelles de Thomas, qui a traversé le temps avec le robot KB-28,
ou plutôt Eliot comme il aime se faire appeler ?
Mais si ! Ils sont à la recherche d'Iris.
Et ça tombe bien, car il la retrouve saine et sauve.
Assise sur un trône dans un château au Moyen-âge.
Pas le genre d'endroit où  tu recroises une ex,
N'est-ce pas Thomas ?
Thomas - "Iris ?!"
Iris - Thomas ? Mais qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?
Thomas - Mais non ! Toi ! Toi, qu'est-ce que tu  fous là ?
Eliot- Iris, il y a un problème
Iris - Attendez, pourquoi le robot à café de mon père et mon ex se retrouvent au Moyen-âge dans mon château ?
Thomas - Oh ça me fais tellement plaisir de te voir Iris !
*Bruit d'épée* Chevalier - Ma reine ! Connaissez-vous ces intrus ? Voulez-vous qu'on les élimines sur-le-champ ?
Iris - Oui, oui. Euh, enfin non, non ! Oui, je les connais et non, on les tue pas.
Thomas - Tu vas rire mais je pensais que tu m'avais quitté !
Iris - Oh, putain...
Thomas - T'es juste dans une autre époque. Mais t'inquiète ma chérie, je te ramène dans le présent
Iris - Oh là là ! Thomas, j'voulais éviter cette situation !
Eliot - Désolé d'interrompre les retrouvailles. Iris, il y a un problème avec le Docteur Simon.
Iris - Attends KB-28, t'as dis quoi sur mon père ?
Thomas - Oui, bon, euh, kidnappé ou tombé dans une autre époque, euh, on s'en fou !
Le plus important, c'est que... *oh nan* ... On est ensemble ... Et on retourne chez nous.
Iris - Non, Thomas on n'est plus ensemble.
Eliot -Iris... *Quuuoi?* ... Le docteur Simon a disparu.
Iris - KB-28, c'est normal que mon père ai disparu, il voyage dans le temps !
Thomas - Attends Iris ...
Iris - Il a inventé la machine. Il s'en sert, sinon c'est, c'est con.
Thomas - J'com..prends pas ...euuh
Iris - Thomas je sais que ça doit te faire un choc, mais oui, je viens du futur et je voyages d'époques en époques.
Thomas - J'en reviens pas...
Iris- J'voulais pas te le dire.
Thomas- ... on est plus en couple !
Eliot - Sa capacité à accepter le voyage dans le temps est impressionnante.(parlant de Thomas)
Thomas- Oh il me faut de l'eau.
Iris- Euh ... c'est pas de l'eau. C'est de l'eau de vie
[recrache et tousse presque a en vomir]
Eliot- Iris, ton père a vraiment disparu.
Tous ceux qui voyagent laissent des traces temporelles.
On peut les localiser et voir par où ils sont passés.
Mais le Docteur Simon, plus rien. Impossible de savoir où il est.
iris- Tu crois que mon père est ... est décédé ?
Thomas- Eeet beiin moi, je trouves que twaa avec ta robe de reine,
Tu ressemble plutôt à la reine des s... (se met à vomir)
Eliot- Non, je pense qu'il est encore en vie. J'ai été activé à distance par ton père.
J'ai pensé que c'était pour que je lui serves un café.
Je l'ai cherché mais il était introuvable au laboratoire.
J'ai pris la dernière machine à voyager dans le temps pour essayer de le localiser ... IMPOSSIBLE !
Alors je me suis dit que tu savais peut-être où il était ?
[Bruit d'homme en armure]Thomas - Attendez la statue qui brille elle a pas bougé là ? Z'avez vu ?
Iris- C'est un chevalier en armure du c*n
[Bruit d'épée] Chevalier en armure- Ma reine ! Je peux l'éliminer d'un coup d'épée si vous voulez ?
Iris- C'est très tentant, j'avoue. Mais non.
KB-28 je vais vérifier ton histoire. Ma machine à voyager est dans mes quartier, suis moi.
Thomas- Et ben KB-28 il s'appelle Eliot d'abord,
sinon c'est robophobe parce que ... je sais plus pourquoi.
C'est pas une machine à qui on donne des ordres !
Eliot tu peux me porter sur ton dos ? Le sol il arrête pas de bouger.
Eliot- Ton taux d'alcoolémie est ... très élevé. Monte Thomas.
Thomas- Ah c'est bien. Gentille machine.
Iris- J'ai pas de nouvelles de mon père depuis un moment. Tu sais qu'on s'entends pas très bien.
Peut-être que ma machine pourra le localiser plus facilement.
[Porte qui s'ouvre]
- Ahh
- Aliénor ?
Aliénor- Oh ma reine ! Vous ici !
Iris- Tu fais quoi ici ? Tu dois nettoyer les latrines, pas ma chambre !
Aliénor- Euh, je passes juste un coup de plumeau, rien de plus. Mais je m'en vais.
(Hoquet)Thomas - Elle à l'air louche la dame.
Eliot- Iris, elle tient la machine dans son dos.
Thomas- Oh j'ai envie de re-vomir.
Iris- Quoi ?! Aliénor lâche ça tout de suite !
Aliénor (d'unton un peu maléfique)- Ah ah ! Dame Iris, j'ai percé votre secret !
C'est à cause de vous et de cet objet magique que les malheurs sont tombés sur mon mari et moi même !
Iris- Rends ma machine avant de faire une connerie !
Aliénor- Ah ah ! Vous êtes démunie désormais.
Je vais pouvoir récupérer mon trone en pressant les boutons de cette boîte magique.
iris- Aliénor !
Aliénor- Maintenant Dame Iris...
Iris- Aliénor !!
Aliénor- Mettez vous à genoux et demandez moi pardon pour l'injure que vous avez portée à notre famille qui est ...
[Bruit de la machine temporelle]
Thomas- Oh ! La dame elle est partie.
Iris- Oh la conne ! Elle s'est téléportée avec ma machine
Eliot- C'était qui ?
Iris- Aliénor de Castille. La reine du château.
Elle a les boules parce que quand je suis arrivée j'ai fais emprisonner le roi et je lui ai donné un boulot de servante.
Et je regrette parce que cette conne a pris ma machine !
Thomas- Et ben c'est bien fais pour ta gueule de lâcheuse
Iris- Oh j'en peux plus faites le taire !
Eliot- J'ai quelque chose qui peux le réveiller
Iris- Ah oui, c'est vrai que tu fais du café
Eliot- Ça va lui faire l'effet d'un coup de fouet
Thomas- Euh c'est de moi que vous parlez ?
Eliot- C'est pour toi Thomas
[Bruit d'électrisation et douleur de Thomas]
Iris- Anw, le taser. C'est encore mieux. Depuis quand t'as ça toi ?
Eliot- Je me suis ajouté cette fonctionnalité avant de partir.
Thomas- Putain mais Eliot tu as failli me tuer
Iris- C'est génial
[Bruit robotique]
Eliot- Un cappuccino ?
Thomas- Euuh volontier
iris- C'est VRAIMENT le moment ?
[Bruit de cafetière et de gobelet]
Iris- Bon un déca pour moi
[Bruit de café qui coule] - Très bien. [Bruit robotique]
Thomas- Ah y'a le dessin d'une fleur dans la crème. C'est mignon Eliot
- Merci.
iris- Bon alors KB... heum ... Éliott c'est ça ?
Thomas- Houlà c'est chaud.
Iris- Bon on va devoir utiliser ta machine pour retrouver mon père
Est-ce que t'as des traces de lui avant sa disparition
Eliot- Oui. Il a beaucoup changé d'époques avant de disparaître. Mais j'ai tout enregistré.
Iris- Parfait ! Voilà ce qu'on va faire :
On s'barre du Moyen-âge, on dépose Thomas chez sa mère à son époque, ...
Thomas- Quoi ?
Iris- Ensuiite on suit les traces de mon père
On cherche des informations c'qui faisait euh avec qui il échangeais peut-être
ça nous mènera a lui
Thomas- QEUH Comment ça je euh rentre chez moi?!
Iris- Bah c'est dangereux de voyager dans le temps et toi
Thomas- RAAh j'en suis pas capable hein c'est CA?!
Je peux être super utile ET en même temps on peux en profiter pour clarifier notre situation c'est pas mal
Iris- Je vois que tu t'en fous de mon père et que tu veux juste être avec moi
Thomas- Ah euh c'est ton père qu'on cherche nan mais c'est que j'étais bourré en même temps
Je suis l'homme de la situation pour retrouver ton père! Qui doit être quelqu'un de très charmant
Iris- C'est un con
Thomas- Héé comment tu parles de mon beau père la(pfouu d'Iris)(bruit de batterie faible)
Eliot- Désolé de vous l'apprendre comme ça maiis j'ai plus assez de batterie pour voyager dans le temps
Iris- OH NON
Me dis pas qu'on n'est coincés ici
Eliot- J'ai puiser dans mes réserves avec mon taser
Thomas- ET BAH VOILA ça ça c'est une mission pour moi tu vas voir chuis indispensable
[pas de Thomas]
Thomas-EUUUH alors
Iris- On peut savoir ce que tu fais la?
Thomas- Je chercheuh les prises
Iris- Nan mais tu te doutes bien que il n'y a pas de prises ICI ON N'EST EN 1314!
Thomas- Peut-être derrière le lit? AH NON JE SAIS j'ai vu ça dans un documentaire a la télé
On va sur le toit d'une mairie quand il fait de l'orage on mets un cable
Entre l'antenne et Eliot on attends qu'il fasse UN ECLAIR
Eliot-THOMAS ça c'est dans le film RETOUR VERS LE FUTUR
Iris as-tu un petit objet électronique ça suffirait largement
Iris- MAIS OUI j'ai un téléphone portable je l'ai filé au Roi a la place de son royaume
IL EST DANS LES CACHOTS
Thomas-Laisser son royaume a la place d'un téléphone portable?
Iris- Ouais y'a des vidéos pornos dessus ça la rendu dingue dès qu'il m'as filé sa place
Je l'ai fait emprisoner et j'ai réduit la reine en esclavage
ON Y EST
Thomas- tu tu TU Regardes du porno Iris?!
Iris- Bah ouais comme toutes les filles
Thomas- AAH les filles du futur regarde du porno
Iris- Non les filles regardent du porno [bruit de cellule]
Mais NOUS dans le futur on le dit
Roi- WOW faut frapper avant d'ouvrir
Thomas-C'est moi ou le Roi a son pantalon baissé
Parce que la je vois toute sa
Roi- J'AI DIT QU'IL FALLAIT FRAPPER AVANT D'OUVRIR!!
Encore merci ma reine pour la pierre plate magique
ET les images de femme qui bougeeent hmhm
Thomas- Est ce qu'il peut remonter son pantalon
Eliot- PARFAIT Iris ce téléphone fera l'affaire
Roi- Nn NON NONNON rendez moi les images
JE VEUX VOIR LES FEMMES SANS POILS
Thomas- Iris c'est horrible ce que tu fais au roi
découvrir le porno et en être privé juste après ça doit faire très mal
[bruit d'halètement] MA REINE [pleurs] le peuple est révolté
I...ILS VEULENT VOTRE TÊTE ET RECUPERER LE ROII
Iris- QUE QUOI MAIS!? pourquoi ils se révoltent d'un coup laa
Serviteur effrayé- c'est une chanson qu'ils ont apprises qu'il leurs a ouvert les yeuux[pleurs] un chant révolutionnaires
Eliot-MAIS c'est la chanson de Thomas
Thomas- HE MAIS OUAIS C'EST MA CHANSON VOUS VOYEZ JE PEUT-ÊTRE UTILE
LES gens m'écoutent
Iris- PAS DU TOUT ILS VEULENT ME COUPER LA TÊTE
Et je déteste cette chanson en plus
C'est en parti pour ça que j'ai quitter ton époque pour ça Thomas
AH donc on est toujours ensemble
[bruit de batterie pleine]Eliot- C'EST BON j'ai vidé la batterie du téléphone
On peux quitter cette époque!
Iris-AAAAh enfin une bonne nouvelle,MON CHER ROI j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer que vous récuperer votre royaume
C'est cool hein?
NAh le royaume ne m'intéresse pas je veux LA PIERRE PLATE AVEC LES FEMMES NUES
Servant- OH les révolutionnaires ils arrivent!
ILS ONT DEJA EXECUTES LA MOITIE DU CHATEAUU
Iris-Bon Bah démerdez vous hein nous ON SE CASSE! KB...euh Eliot ou est allés mon père?
J'ai quelque chose à(bip bip)Berlin(bip bip) en 1944
Iris-Oh non pffou
Bon bah c'est parti
Thomas- De quoi iiil se passe quoi la?
Iris-Mais t'es vraiment nul en histoire!
Thomas- Roh bah ça va je voyage pas dans le temps pour apprendre tout ces trucs moi
Iris-Il suffit d'aller a l'école MERDE! Eliot! Cassons nous!
TIENS le roi il te reste 2% amuse toi bien
Roi- Merci Dame Iris oh Oh mille mercis
Eliot- J'ai synchronisé la trace temporelle du docteur Simon rester près de moi
Direction L'ALLEMAGNE [voix virile]
Retemporalisation IMMEDIATE!
Thomas- Bon bah c'est partiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
[bruit de voyage] toujours avec le iiiiii de Thomas
[bruit de mitraillete] Attentioon
Thomas- Aah oui... c'est la guerre en faite...
[Musique]
[VOIX OFF] Bien vu Thomas! C'est même la seconde guerre mondiale
Comme on l'apprends dans le programme de 4 ème
Désormais cher auditeur(trice) tu en sais plus
Sur la quête d'Eliot il faut retrouver
LE DOCTEUR SIMON
L'inventeur de la machine à voyager dans le temps
Vont-ils le retrouver?
Ecoute le prochain épisode
MOI! JE SAIS DEJA TOUT
Je te l'ai dit
[MUSIQUE]
[Porte qui s'ouvre] MON ROI (frapper la porte!)ON VOUS LIBERE VOUS ETES LIBRE TOUT VAS MIEUX Désor...
Vous avez votre pantalon baissé (roi- les images ont disparu)
OOOH les femmes (pleurs)
OU SONT LES FEEEMMMMMEEEES??!!
Cyprien- Merci d'avoir écouter le deuxième épisode de l'épopée Temporelle n'hésite pas a t'abonner et a mettre un pouce en l'air ET
A LA SEMAINE PROCHAINE :3